being on
scp-173 detail isn't easy these duties
of strict observation fall on a
bi-weekly basis when
scp-173's enclosure needs to be cleaned
the reddish-brown substance on the floor
is a natural output of scp-173
a combination of feces and blood while
the foundation has put up with a lot of
depraved behavior from its scps it draws
the line at poor hygiene they routinely
send in a crew of three d-class
personnel to clean up the mess but the
bigger chore isn't the scrubbing and
mopping at all but rather keeping
scp-173 docile to do so the line of
sight must not be broken at any time
with scp-173
personnel assigned to enter the
container are instructed to alert one
another before blinking if this protocol
is not followed
scp-173 attacks by snapping the neck at
the base of the skull it is at its core
a high-stakes staring contest the crew
is intelligently divided into their
tasks only one of them actually has
janitorial duties and even then the
mopper's most relevant skill isn't even
related to cleaning at all his greatest
strength must be his ability to trust
other people as he takes his mop to the
floor he hands over his life to his crew
who protect him with their focus and
attention on
scp-173 it is without a doubt one of the
cruelest and most stressful jobs anyone
could ever have but not every horror
story is found in the trenches of terror
those with mops on the front lines have
their work cut out for them but even the
researchers with their warm lab coats
and boring bureaucratic obligations
aren't safe from danger this is the
story of jake skoll a researcher who for
reasons we will tactfully tease you with
until the video's witty end has been
reassigned to scp-170
director fordham brought the bad news
like a bag of coal you're being
reassigned he said with a slight smirk
on his face continuing to be preoccupied
with his paperwork as if this news was
secondary to what he was doing right
there and then but it wasn't secondary
to jack's skull it was the center of
their life now not even just the center
it was the center peripheral and outer
bounds of their life their assignments
were everything and everything was about
to change a pregnant silence followed
the announcement jake shkol couldn't
find a response and they weren't even
sure there was one to be found no matter
how deep they dug what came out wasn't
as much of a retort as a reaction that
involuntary bodily response to events
that weren't expected that awkward and
afraid muttering of fear and confusion
ah
i'm to be
reassigned is that what you're saying
research your skull blinked a few times
confused their feet sunk into the deep
forest green shag on the floor a
spectrum of thoughts cascaded through
their mind as they searched harder and
harder for a reason
digging deeper and deeper only to find
another treasure chest full of nothing
is my work not sufficient on scp
director fordham looked up and gave them
the fixed pointed stare they'd grown to
dread over the past six months of course
not jake i recognize what you've done
and we want to put you somewhere i feel
you deserve and serve the foundation of
course we're putting you on a very
important and special object again
fordham gave that smirk that damn smirk
sure his words and tone presented
themselves as the truth but his face
said otherwise the devious positioning
of his lip suggested that there was a
layer of sinister subtext to his speech
but jake skoll couldn't pick up on the
cues there's no room to read someone
else's poker face when all of your
attention is on the crappy hand you've
just been dealt jake skull's eyes fell
to the desk reassigned the word rang
like church bells why god their work
with
scp-3872 as a consulting chemist was
going slowly to be truthful but they
didn't think it was to the point that
they needed reassignment
alright
which project am i assigned to
the time between the question and the
answer was the longest of jake's life
the uncertainty felt like an eternity
fordham tapped a few symbols accessing
skull's profile and added an entry in
their security clearance he hastily
swiped away all the other files listed
and turned back to face skull you have
access to it now please get on the first
plane to site 19. your dormitory
contents are already packed up jake
reached into their pocket to check the
notification on their cell phone
scp-3872 file removed
scp-2593 file removed
scp-173
file added they turned around and walked
slowly through the corridors towards the
transportation hub on the outskirts of
the site they opened the file on their
phone and quickly scanned the oddly
phrased report attempting to make sense
of what they were reading skull's
eyebrows raised to the heavens as they
noticed the timestamp on containment
scp-173 was one of the first one of the
few objects that the foundation came to
possess through some organization or
another without losing its information
they tried their best to remain
optimistic in their interpretation of
these new life events and for a moment
they thought this might be a good thing
for me swiping down they came to the
section about assigned researchers the
people whose steps they would be
following in and where were those steps
leading them the list was impressive
from dr kondraki to dr bright these
people were all legends in their own
right and so if they could just follow
their footsteps they reasoned they would
end their journey in a good place they
imagined their new career path straight
to the top of this mountain of success
maybe they would become the face of the
foundation maybe they would accomplish
so much that they'd had a statue erected
in their honor that people travel far
and wide to visit and take pictures with
maybe this would be a good thing they
wanted to think i need the first plane
to site 19. they said with confidence
i've been reassigned and so jake skull
took to the air and clung to the stream
as long as they could but no matter how
heavy a sleeper reality shakes everyone
awake eventually
six years later jake skull could hear
the years pass but not only could they
hear it they could feel it their body
was decaying in a way inconsistent with
our biological understanding of age
scp-173 the legendary object the first
the original the statue it was chipping
away at the soul of jake's skull it was
carving a statue of its own hacking at
stone until it was nothing and that's
what jake's skull felt like
nothing it was torture when they arrived
they quickly reviewed the research
materials every word had become burned
into their memory all 233 words of them
the additional research materials turned
out to be a few scribbled pages by board
researchers a few had made hypotheses
that it all turned out to be nonsense
there was a locked filing cabinet but
every time skoll requested it be opened
maintenance told them that the control
room was designated low priority and
they would get to it eventually over the
past six years jake skull had made 18
separate transfer requests they wanted
out but all of them had been denied it
was as if they were in high school again
asking dates to prom and getting hit
with no thank yous feeling none of the
politeness backed into their syntax
understanding only the brutal reality of
the phrase no
they were stuck here technically a level
3 staff now but without any rights to
view or work on any other objects they
were given a promotion but it withheld
all the perks and benefits that come
with it they were stuck in a loop of
pats on the back people extended them
their hand but it was always with an
empty palm giving them nothing to hold
on to but a gesture they were assigned a
staff of four 3d class all of which were
older men and a lazy level 2 security
officer who slouched in this office
chair meeting the bare minimum
requirements to be considered a living
human being the d-class were all quite
docile they came in once a week mopped
the floor mumbled clear to each other
and left they lived within this exact
structure no new days became an unspoken
motto these recurring 24 hours passed
slowly if there were no clocks to prove
the passing of time they would have
every reason to believe it had frozen
over but occasionally ever so
occasionally the day would deviate just
slightly they'd hear something a scrape
and the sounds of movement jake would
flip open the observation ports on the
double concrete lock and examine
scp-173 but jake could take offense to
such language examining might be the
wrong word more accurately they would
just look at it because there was
nothing to examine there was nothing to
observe
scp-173 was already understood michael
jordan doesn't take a microscope to the
ball every time he plans to dribble he
knows every detail of it by heart his
fingertips know the grooves his hand-eye
coordination knows how to control it his
right arms built-in apt for physics
knows exactly how much force to put into
each shot and at what trajectory to aim
we are told to learn something new every
day but the truth is there comes a day
when the learning stops when we know all
that we will ever know and this felt
true to jake they understood scp-173
there was nothing more for them to see
it was just concrete revamp and some
spray paint that was it and that was all
that it would ever be there was nothing
to find nothing to determine nothing for
the researcher to research their job was
done but they kept having to work it
their identity no longer fit but they
kept having to put it on each and every
morning when jake first got there they
collected samples of the concrete some
of the rebar some spray paint they were
determined to find something worthy of
research after four weeks they'd gotten
sick of getting no replies from admin
and they cracked the locks on the filing
cabinet finding the research notes of
all the previous researchers all of the
legendary doctor's notes turned out to
be doodles and random to-do lists which
had nothing to do with the object after
six weeks they gave up on taking samples
after eight weeks they brought a game
boy after 10 they started bringing in
anything they could to pass the time a
yo-yo a collection of short stories a
packet of hot sauce they felt bad
throwing away a piece of string to cut
off circulation to their index finger
for no other reason than to make sure
they were still a human relying on blood
oh yes jake skull was bored so
very bored they thought if anyone could
bring the phrase bored to death to
fruition it would be them these days
they shuffled in waved at the guard and
sat down at their little control room
where there was a terminal which by the
way didn't have an internet connection
and tried to stay sane fast forward a
few years and jake barely fit into his
chair to clarify no they did not
purchase a new tiny chair out of boredom
they got fat out of boredom their life
brought them no joy and so what they
couldn't get from living they searched
for in eating but there was no
fulfillment to be found at the center of
the tootsie pop jake stood with a grunt
as the light came on and the 3d class
were escorted to the control room with
the mops and buckets in tow thanks jimmy
was the only conversation they had with
the new security staff the old guard had
retired some time in the 8th year
honestly jay couldn't even remember the
d-class had gotten older too most of
them now grey-haired but still assigned
to the project the security guard walked
over and thumbed towards the break room
hey jake i'm going to get coffee if
anything happens seal the door you know
the drill just keep an eye on the ds
jake buzzed the doors open and stood
inside the door frame keeping their eyes
on the statue most of the time but but
wandering over the containment chamber a
long time ago they might have been
concerned but the d-classes they worked
with weren't very violent frankly they
had worked with these men long enough
that they extended a small measure of
trust all of them did their jobs without
complaining and never had made a mistake
in 10 years while the years of
repetition wore them out the job itself
didn't even feel like labor they had
perfected the art of the staring contest
they were confident and they had reason
to be as the years went on although they
collected no new data on scp-173
they did collect evidence evidence that
they were capable of containing it while
they learned nothing new of importance
about scp-173
they learned about themselves they
learned that they were a good crew and
it was because of this confidence even
if rightfully earned that success
crumbled when in a room with scp-173
you have to assume everything will go
wrong because
anything can go wrong and eventually it
will and when that time comes you have
to be prepared procedure said jake had
to have someone armed in the room with
any d-class jake looked down at their
hip double checked the pistol there they
knew how to use it but figured he never
would have to draw it the routine
cleaning began claire where claire it
was the same old same old until suddenly
it wasn't clear
oh no i think i'm having a snap what hey
hey nick are you snap oh god no i don't
wanna snap jake's eyes shot up as the
statue stood inches away its green eyes
stared directly into their soul in their
periphery jay could see the 3d class
with their head turned at odd angles
jake desperately reached out for the
emergency containment button on the wall
they hadn't ever had to use it and it
was supposed to be easy to find but of
course it wasn't they were called the
manual saying move your hand anywhere
along the right hand wall the button
takes up most of the wall it will seal
off the containment chamber and scp-173
from breaching containment they moved
their hand exactly how their memory of
the manual instructed him but it wasn't
there there was nothing to press there
was nothing to save them jake's hands
grew desperate and their eyes began to
water just as they started to close a
last thought crossed their mind move
your hand anywhere along the left-hand
wall the button takes up most of the
wall it will seal off the containment
chamber and scp-173 from breaching
containment of course a classic mix-up
50-50 chances never favored the
flustered their fight-or-flight
instincts were contradicting each other
was reaching for a button fighting or
was it flighting they were in their head
deep in trenches of overthinking finally
they regained their composure their hand
darted out to the left and they started
to push down on the button the red of
the emergency button filled their vision
as the green eyes of scp-173 slipped
just barely out of
snap director kinsley stood outside of
the meeting room a few minutes before
the weekly briefing in the site 2-117
administrative wing fordham do you
remember jake skull ah yeah i sure do
just got a report from 19. looks like
there was a breach and they bit it
fordham waved off a few colleagues who
were about to enter the meeting room his
conversation with director kinsley
wasn't over he went on to tell him that
he was just about to approve jake
skull's transfer after all these years
jake had been sending requests to leave
scp-173
their wish was about to be granted but
instead they were reassigned to the
grave what a cruel twist isn't it that
is of course if it were actually true
fordham gave his patented smirk
just kidding the only researchers to
ever get out of that post needed friends
in very high places skroll to his
dutchman did not so what exactly did
skoll do to deserve this it is known
that those who are sent to scp-173 have
made mistakes if you disrespect your
boss you might be reassigned to scp-173
if you don't follow foundation policy
you might be reassigned to scp-173
if you leak information to the public
you might be reassigned to scp-173
if you are jake's scroll however it
doesn't take quite as much so i will
pose the question once more what
horrible thing could jake have done
could they have been plotting to help an
array of scps escape could they have
been smuggling dangerous equipment from
the lab and selling it on the black
market could they have somehow been
responsible for every casualty in
foundation history or could it have been
something much much
smaller like occasionally parking in
their boss's favorite spot on site 217 a
lot you must understand which doesn't
have a signed parking now go check out
scp-173 the complete story and scp-173
origin story how 173 got to site-19 for
more tales of the iconic scp-173